Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Che cos'è la bellezza di un'opera d'arte?
Il detto comune dice:
"Non è bello ciò che è bello,
ma è bello ciò che piace"
e questo ci indurrebbe a pensare
che la bellezza debba essere soggettiva,
frutto di valori personali.
Tuttavia c'è un'implicazione,
in questa frase, che non possiamo negare:
"Non è bello ciò che è bello".
E questo sta a indicare
che ci debba essere una bellezza
comunemente, oggettivamente
ma anche universalmente
considerata come tale.
E mi riferisco alla bellezza di un'opera
non figlia del fashion trend del momento,
ma il cui valore perdura nel tempo
perché si fa portatrice, contenitore
dell'essenza della matrice umana,
della nostra natura.
Bene, vorrei argomentare
queste mie riflessioni
che nascono da anni di studi
nelle neuroscienze, in psicologia
presentandovi questa semplice immagine.
Quello che vi sto mostrando
sono i meravigliosi primi passi
nel mondo della rappresentazione
di bambini molto piccoli.
È ovviamente la rappresentazione
di un corpo umano:
a tre anni vediamo soltanto un abbozzo
che diventa via via più complesso,
più arricchito di dettagli
man mano che il bambino cresce.
E, per quanto io possa pensare
che questi bambini siano bravi
rispetto alla loro età anagrafica
a rappresentare la figura umana,
certo io non le posso considerare
delle vere e proprie opere d'arte.
Almeno, non so voi, ma io forse
sul camino della sala non le metterei.
E direte voi: "Certo,
chi ce l'ha un camino in sala?".
Tuttavia, vedete, i genitori
di questi bambini -
e io dico i genitori per esemplificare
ma indico qualsiasi persona
che abbia una relazione affettiva
con questi bambini:
i nonni, gli zii.
Ecco, loro non la pensano
allo stesso modo:
quando guardano questo disegno, sì,
forse all'inizio farebbero
un'analisi un po' fredda, così,
un po' sintetica del disegno;
ma andrebbero subito oltre.
Quello che loro incomincerebbero a vedere
non sono più questi segni grafici,
che sono chiaramente il frutto
di un'abilità ancora immatura,
da parte del bambino, di rappresentare.
Quello che loro vedono
è il progresso evolutivo,
lo sviluppo di questi bambini
che finalmente sono capaci di disegnare,
di fare qualcosa che ha un senso.
Quello che loro vedono
è la disposizione affettiva
di questi bambini:
l'affetto di questi bambini
che hanno fatto il disegno
magari proprio per loro.
Quello che loro vedono
è l'emozione di questi bambini
mentre mostrano il disegno
con orgoglio, con soddisfazione:
"Guarda cosa ho fatto!"
E questo emoziona mamma,
papà, i nonni, gli zii
che guardando al disegno
pensano: "È bello!".
Vedete, quando la rappresentazione
viene vissuta nell'essenza del suo valore,
quando assume un senso,
un significato per chi la guarda,
ecco che diventa bella ai suoi occhi.
"Beauty is in the eyes of the beholder",
così dicono gli inglesi.
L'opera d'arte.
L'opera d'arte fa
essenzialmente la stessa cosa:
produce nello spettatore un'esperienza
analoga a quella vissuta dal genitore,
con la differenza
che non lo fa soltanto
per mamma, papà, i nonni e gli zii,
ma lo fa per tutti.
Come?
Attraverso delle tecniche
di brain imaging, non invasive,
siamo andati a vedere
che cosa succede nel cervello di persone
mentre osservavano delle opere d'arte
che possiamo tranquillamente
definire "belle".
Pensiamo ai nostri classici della pittura,
i classici della scultura,
la cui bellezza è definita, anche,
dell'armonia delle proporzioni:
pensiamo alla proporzione aurea.
Ecco, quando queste persone
guardavano delle immagini di arte,
delle immagini di opere artistiche,
noi vedevamo nel loro cervello
che si attivavano diverse aree,
così come sta succedendo a voi
in questo preciso momento.
E, nel complesso,
tutte queste attivazioni
ci raccontano una storia
e ci insegnano almeno tre cose.
Uno: quando noi guardiamo un'opera d'arte,
non la vediamo soltanto
con i nostri occhi,
non la rappresentiamo soltanto
graficamente, pittoricamente,
ma la sentiamo.
La sentiamo fisicamente,
con il nostro corpo:
l'opera d'arte è in grado
di attivarci fisicamente.
La seconda cosa
che ci insegnano questi studi
è che quando noi guardiamo
un'opera d'arte "bella",
questa è in grado di suscitare in noi
delle emozioni, dei sentimenti,
delle esperienze viscerali
di benessere ma anche di disagio.
E la terza cosa
che ci insegnano questi studi
è che attraverso l'opera d'arte
noi siamo in grado di entrare
nell'esperienza e nel vissuto
di qualcun altro.
O, detto in altri termini,
lasciamo che l'esperienza,
il vissuto di qualcun altro entri in noi.
E questo è molto importante
perché vuol dire che quando noi guardiamo
un'opera d'arte "bella"
l'esperienza che noi proviamo
non è solo nostra,
ma si porta dietro l'esperienza
e il vissuto di qualcun altro.
Di chi?
Dell'artista, naturalmente.
Un artista che è stato in grado,
attraverso l'uso sapiente
delle forme, dei colori, dimensioni,
spazi, simmetrie, proporzioni, prospettive
ma anche violazioni delle regole,
di raccontare una sua visione del mondo,
di raccontare una sua
rappresentazione della realtà,
un suo vissuto interiore,
una sua esperienza personale:
esperienza che, attraverso l'opera d'arte,
diventa un'esperienza condivisa.
Ma, se ci pensate, noi siamo esseri
strutturati biologicamente
allo stesso modo
e quindi i nostri processi
sono condivisi e "condivisibili".
E quanto più il racconto dell'opera d'arte
si avvicinerà a un nostro
vissuto personale,
tanto più l'opera sarà per noi evocativa:
ecco perché alcune opere
ci parlano di più rispetto ad altre.
E l'opera che sarà in grado
di esercitare quell'effetto su di noi
potrà essere detta opera bella.
Così come, nella sua esperienza personale,
il genitore non vede più
le linee e i cerchi,
ma viene assorbito dall'essenza
del significato del disegno di suo figlio,
così, nella sua esperienza condivisa,
lo spettatore, l'osservatore
di un'opera d'arte
sarà assorbito dall'essenza
dell'esperienza
che l'artista abile avrà saputo
comunicare e trasmettere
attraverso l'opera d'arte.
E l'opera d'arte fa questo per tutti.
Non guarda in faccia nessuno:
lo fa in modo indiscriminato.
Tuttavia, non tutti siamo sempre
in grado di coglierne l'effetto.
Platone, nella sua visione
oggettivista della bellezza, diceva:
"La bellezza è la proprietà di un oggetto
di evocare e di suscitare
un'esperienza piacevole
in qualsiasi spettatore
che sia predisposto".
In qualsiasi spettatore
che sia predisposto.
Non bisogna essere colti
per poter apprezzare
la bellezza di un'opera d'arte:
non è la cultura a fare la differenza.
Quello che fa la vera differenza
è la nostra predisposizione,
la nostra disposizione:
il nostro atteggiamento
nei confronti dell'opera.
Noi potremmo attraversare
Firenze mille volte,
e mai sentirci veramente mossi
dalla bellezza che ci circonda.
Oppure, davanti a un'opera d'arte,
potremmo fermarci,
entrare in uno stato che possiamo definire
immersivo, contemplativo,
e lasciare che l'opera
faccia il suo lavoro:
che cominci il suo dialogo con noi.
E allora ecco che avviene la magia.
E allora ecco che davanti
al David di Michelangelo
non vedremo più soltanto
una scultura ben fatta,
ma incominceremo ad apprezzare la postura,
a notare la linea sottile delle vene,
a sentire con il nostro
corpo, fisicamente,
la tensione dei muscoli
oppure anche il rilassamento,
a entrare nella profondità di uno sguardo
che guarda qualcosa, lì all'orizzonte.
E allora ci interrogheremo,
e quando saremo completamente
immersi in questa esperienza
lontano dalle voci,
dagli sguardi delle persone
che ci circondano,
allora potremo continuare,
potremo incominciare a sentire
questo moto interiore,
a provare questa esperienza viscerale,
questa esperienza corporea,
ma anche essere trasportati
in luoghi dove non siamo mai stati,
o dove non siamo mai voluti andare.
E quando parlo di luoghi,
non intendo soltanto luoghi fisici;
ma anche luoghi interiori,
perché la vera arte anche questo sa fare.
E allora, sarà lì che noi assaporeremo
la vera essenza della bellezza.
Una bellezza che non è la bellezza
del David di per sé:
ma, attraverso il David, è la bellezza
dell'esperienza che stiamo vivendo.
Un'esperienza che è universale
in quanto noi tutti parte di un sistema
che si muove secondo le stesse dinamiche.
E fin quando la natura umana
sarà così come la conosceremo,
come la conosciamo
noi oggi, in ogni tempo,
incontrando un David
penseremo: "Che bello!".
Grazie.
(Applausi)